- [Narrator] Tokyo is a city
that needs no introduction.
In Japan's capital, modernity
and history live side by side.
(upbeat music)
And when it comes to street
food, it's no different,
with recipes passed down
through generations,
the flavors here can transcend time.
We begin with a snack that uses an often
overlooked ingredient
in street food: octopus.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] Next up, a dish that has
taken decades for one man to perfect.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Gyoza may not be Japanese,
but we found an amazing
shop that we had to share.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] Originally from Hiroshima,
this next dish has
become a staple in Tokyo.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Finally, we
end with something sweet
at a shop playing with
traditional flavors.
(upbeat music)
(lively music)